ce que lui voilà il rêve de bateaux et
rêve devient ses variantes pour moi
c'est le luxe absolu vraiment raide
c'est d'abord
combien de
40 mètres 40 - vous y allez pas comme un
outsider
oui un gros bâton quand même temps on a
eu 1 à l'époque échappe alors alors non
je en fait j'ai eu de la chance j'ai au
moment juste avant de divorcer j'allais
acheter un bateau dieu me préserve les
pas acheter pour sa défense oui alors
vous auriez coulé avec
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
évidemment louer un bateau le bateau
mère et jamais vous voulez acheter un
bateau de waimes un bon jeu sato 40
mètres 40 mais quand vous voulez mais en
voyant les basques sont en stock bateaux
de 40 mais c'est allé beaucoup beaucoup
d'argent c'est ça déjà à l'époque même
quand vous gagnez beaucoup vous importe
quoi à tout et n'importe quoi parce que
là vous vous mettiez dans le rouge
direct non mais bon bah ça se clôt sa se
rentabilise voilà on peut voir oui ah
ouais quand même charter faisait quoi je
vous dire la vérité je pense que vous
avez une très bonne nouvelle de ne pas
l'acheter je pense que vous auriez été
encore plus embêté lewis etc
il ya un problème on a un problème c'est
une barque
[Rires]
au climat
n'est pas
rien à faire cyril c'est pas ton rêve
tôt
c'est quoi mon rêve j'ai adoré on allait
tourner la carte aux trésors à tahiti je
sais pas qui est allé ici on vraiment tu
te dis voilà si un jour je suis très
très riches mais faire là bas
franchement aller vivre là-bas en
politique il faut avec une maison où
tous les matins tu te réveilles avec une
vue de ouf offert acheter une maison un
tapage adorerait ouais je me dis si un
jour je suis viré
polynésie 1ère tu vous animez des jeux
sur la plage à taez sud je pense que
vous verrez c'est papa qui ne fait que
dire un jour sur la tête
j'élève ma meilleure
[Musique]
alors
voilà c'est son rêve dutheil qui lui
sied le yacht vous ne sais quoi moi je
reste à paris ce que j'adore paris mais
je voudrais si j'avais de l'argent bien
sûr une très belle maison dans à paris
une très belle mais droit et dans paris
mais ils raison maison en banlieue
parisienne jean ou bien vraiment paru
permanent paris ça serait génial homme
est à terre j'ai tâté un pied-à-terre à
la cyril hanouna une vraie
dans la gueule
ça fait deux fois je vous signale et
elle est encore là bas elle aurait
écouté arrêté de dénoncer les
côtés et bernard montiel vous avez été
viré de tf1 pour ça
pour ça disent que je vous dis pas que
c'est
non non non pas d'abord gaz et donc
préserver la batterie dans paris sur
col.red une région mais on voulait quoi
un jardin un jardin une piscine et une
piscine pas forcément la piscine mais ma
jacuzzi moyens jacuzzi pourquoi pas ok
un majordome un majordome banon je m'en
fous ce nom est encore immense dressing
bah ouais away le kiff super grand
dressing et puis une grande salle pour
recevoir mes amis ma famille phares des
grandes imec perdu le plein d'amis ben
voilà c'est le rêve de valérie b c est
sûr qu il y ait ce ça fait plaisir de le
retrouver c'est plaisant de pouvoir
filmer
[Applaudissements]
oui
comme celle mère elle nous a fait une
bonne âme à boston
ça va vraiment mon maximum certes voir
la très très bien c'est quoi ton rêve
toi moi mon rêve franchement si je
gagnais beaucoup d'argent oui ce serait
d'être gestionnaire d'un parc
d'attractions n'en avoir rien par
effraction a pas d'infraction un bon
petit partout et cinq ans entre hal et
on peut les acheter pour 150 millions
d'euros ah ouais à peu près après du
rentabilise sales trucs du métier d'art
cry tu mettais 150 millions de moins
qu'annoncé a compté pour le parc
médicale et humaine
ça vous intéresse
merci elle n'est pas sortie de ne pas
sortir fait voler mon garde y avoir
plusieurs actionnaires d'accor oui on
peut voir pourquoi le billérois
plusieurs actionnaires auprès de nos
demandes et
[Rires]
j'aime à tous avec toi et maxime alors
je t'aime beaucoup l'homme je t'adore
mais je pense que c'est pas le moment
ouais pour l'instant mais on va voir
trouve le parc ouais et puis tu me tiens
au courant des gants très bien j'ai
failli marcher mais c'est hyper rentable
un parc d'attraction sur cette longue
et rentable c'est convaincre m alors moi
mon rêve n'est pas compliqué j'aimerais
avoir une grande propriété avec plein de
d'arbres et un grand verger et
j'aimerais avoir plein de chien et
surtout d'avoir le temps de pouvoir que
être avec lui ah ouais en fait moi mon
rêve c'est d'avoir du temps ah ouais
ouais mais bon je vous en donner
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
on a patiné contrat
n'est pas assez fait pour être brisé
ouais voilà un on embrasse d'ailleurs
mon nico à vous c'est quoi votre rêve
alors moi je n'ai pas d'amis donc ce que
je voudrais faire
un vrai parti à hong kong bah oui avec
fatou et les enfants s'installent au
dernier étage du plus grand building de
hong kong or et ont fait une vraie ville
dans notre champ notre terrasse tout ça
avec des boutiques tout ça pas le
rapport avec les amis étaient heureux là
bas comme j'ai pas d'amis j'en tire les
conséquences ah oui que fatto voilà
parce que là quand je suis là je vois
qu'il n'est pas d'amis si shank je vois
pas que j'ai pas d'amis mais je lançais
remet sur la terrasse explique les faire
avant tout c'est ce que vous allez faire
un tour vous allez voir un psy
[Rires]
alors c'est compliqué ça très vite ça
n'arrête pas de dire je suis son ami est
là ouais mais on s'en fout la maman
rennes et rejoint celui de delphine
comme quoi une ferme avec montfermier
évidemment et plein plein plein
d'animaux des maracas et n'est pas de
casser tout tout tout site rémois de
600 lycéens
balagué l'impression que les deux
nous entende et je lâche rien non c'est
vrai il faut savoir où se met à vendre
avec
des dents la menace c'est vrai c'est
rigolo c'est vrai
c'est maxime guillot au games est le
signe de tout le monde c'est un beau
garçon ça me prend un sens c'est pas le
type dolphin donc il n'est pas parce
qu'elle est c'est pas parce qu'elle a
une vie ailleurs qu'elle ne voit pas que
c'est un beau garçon exactement et aux
masques ont conduit et c'est pas parce
qu'on coût d'une voiture comporte en
produire d'autres exactement bison futé
merci je vous sais qu'au retrait moi je
marche un rêve vous concernant
pas savoir et plus pouvoir pendant
longtemps
ces coups parfaits non moi une grande
propriété sur la mer est effectivement
partant david
webb mais bon c'est pas peine de le dire
on fait chier donc
voilà
votre pied-à-terre à paris à passer à
table montiel comment traire à paris mal
d'autre que monter je termine si on peut
faire nommer une femme et carita ta ta
ta ta ta peacock l'a22 5000 mètres
carrés de jardin merci
dutil
avait déjà c'est pas si je suis pas
vraiment sûr la mer c'est en deuxième
ligne comme on dit chez no way
non alors sur la mer un peu plein
d'animaux que les animateurs phares de
tf1 est en première ligne mais je sais
mais j'ai jamais été farm siba si vous
avez été très fort non c'est donc non je
sais j'ai une bonne et steve vous mettez
vous ne me gênait donc pris autant
clignotants pas
gagner autant nom et et surtout avoir un
cuisinier parce que je sais rien faire
mais c'est vrai à la cuisine y est ça
c'est un rêve ça c'est un luxe oui ah
oui parce que la cuisine me fait chier
j'aime pas ça et j'aimerais bien avoir
un cuisinier d'accord avait d'autres
choses à nous dire non c'était
intéressant non non
alors là tout le contraire de bernard
montiel je rêve d'avoir avec mon
compagnon un restaurant on en rêve on
vit pour ça alain restaurant franco
italien à whitby frêle à la cuisine
italienne baisse qui cuisine très bien
et moi je serai la cuisine française
il convient de blanquette de veau élue
lasagnes bongo les way notre rêve l'on
voudrait faire ça dans dix ans dans dix
ans on sera vieux à la retraite bah
écoutez franchement viendra on mange et
j'espère qu'on aura une petite ristourne
[Rires]
rêve de toute une vie très bien bonsoir
moyennes villes où j'ai toujours rêvé
d'habiter c'est mulhouse le but
[Rires]
la propriété avec plein de chien et
surtout beaucoup de temps d'accord
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ma mère dit j'adore montiel je peux lui
faire la cuisine
mais c'est sûr qu'elle fait bien la
cuisine votre mana elle vous adore le
basket oui parce qu'elle est très on
voit c'est une femme très doux très
agréable
et c'est thomas mercado mais c'est
normal un scénario seuil à quoi vous
vous posez vous les bonnes questions
quoi y a que vous qui m'aimait pas posez
vous les bonnes questions aussi un
vieux l'adorent